at the heart of pipestone minnesota
stands the historic calumet in built in
1887. calumet is a native american word
for peace pipe but sadly peace is
something in short supply at the calumet
inn
the hotel is owned by sisters reina and
vanda smirkovsky
nine months ago their father jim or
daddy as they call him purchased the
hotel for the sisters i'm not sure that
rina and vanda realize how privileged
they are
just because we dress nice doesn't mean
we're spoiled
they are definitely a little bit spoiled
green is not just a little bit spoiled
she's also a little bit of a crybaby
there's just too much trash talking
around here and i can't work with people
like that i'm so sick of being judged
you're gonna have to come down to earth
i cry a lot what was i crying about
after owning the hotel for just six
weeks rina found working a bit much so
she took the weekend off in minneapolis
200 miles away
and she didn't return for three months
while she was away the hotel was left at
the mercy of her younger sister vanda
vanda considers herself very hard
working although she doesn't get out of
bed until three o'clock every afternoon
leaving the hotel under staffed
a lot of times i feel like
people
come to work
just to make tips and for their
paycheck and they're not necessarily
here to take care of this
historic
artifact
i apologize again i'm sorry
thank you thank you very much i do not
think fandom arena should be running a
hotel at all because they don't know
what they're doing and they don't care
about anybody
despite having zero hospitality
experience you know how to use this
vanda and rina think they know best so
they strip the general manager of all
her management duties before rina and
vanda got here i was the general manager
of the calumet and now i'm a front desk
person and a waitress that's what i am
i've got the chicken pita wrap right
here with the girls in charge things of
the hotel have rapidly gone downhill oh
that's moldy oh man
look at this how are your allergies
doing you're a little bit rough
you need your inhaler
with almost no guests coming in vanda
and rena's parents have been forced to
leave their family home in minneapolis
and move into the hotel alongside their
daughters in a desperate attempt to cut
the cost and keep the doors open i'm
work seven days a week
i miss my home very much
if the situation doesn't change fast the
staff will all lose their jobs i can't
do this this is real life like this is
people's jobs this isn't you playing
hotel because you're bored and the hotel
will have to shut its doors forever
if gordon ramsay cannot help rain and
vanda nobody can
and the calumet will close
i'm in the middle of minnesota look at
this place it's like holland it is
incredibly flat windmills everywhere but
no [ __ ] tulips
[Music]
look at the size of that thing
the largest peace pipe in the world
this is it wow this place is huge
and maybe historically looking happy
okay
this is the entrance you're kidding me
this looks like the entrance to a
[ __ ] prison not a hotel
a prison with an atm my god hello
you are kidding me
please come on
i can't believe it it's so dark in here
[ __ ] dungeon hello
stop this
i'm gonna get a light
oh man
that is crazy
right
maybe it's best i turn around and [ __ ]
off home now hello
i feel like a goonie
hey you guys
uh
wow
oh hello hi how are you
when i saw gordon walk in i was very
scared um because i knew that he was you
know trying to check into the hotel are
you running this place by yourself yes
today i am today you are does anyone
work in reception
me yeah are you ready yes so you're
the server and you're on the front desk
yes my name is mandy mandy gordon nice
to see you you're busy yes favors indeed
because you've got diners look after
maybe somebody else should check me in
why do not feel like a proper gm here
hi mandy hey come down and help please
feel like somebody that's here to
kind of cover the extra hours however i
do still get to listen to the complaints
i don't know if you know mandy but
there's a bulb missing there probably um
jim likes to take bulbs out of things so
people can't turn lights on so jim likes
to take bulbs yes jim likes to take bulb
wow so
take the bulb out place the madhouse
oh
hello hi finally finally and first name
is vanda vanda pleased to meet you
likewise gordon good to see you i'm rina
rina nice to see you meet you sisters
yes and owners yes if you don't want me
asking i mean you look very young to be
running a hotel how old are you i'm 27.
wow baby
i'm 32. wow maybes
um and you both run it together yes so
mandy multitasks she does the
she's um actually the general manager
wow general manager head waitress and
she looks like a busa
i'm not happy with her work
it's really difficult to find people who
are motivated to work and who want to
live to live up to our standards
you are in our best room
the melody of love
do you hear people shagging in the next
door
no you must hear something
wow
holy
mackerel is that mould in there i
i wouldn't be surprised if it were mold
uh where's the uh wardrobe so i can hold
my jacket wardrobe um
right over right there
yeah kind of hidden behind the microwave
and moldy refrigerators
i'm feeling really nervous right now i
know that the room was really cluttered
but i didn't realize it was that bad
well at least we have a light bulb
there's a man that goes around knicking
light bulbs out of the lamps mandy said
that he doesn't want them turned on
some guy called jim jim father takes
light bulbs out of the lane he's your
father yeah mum works in the business as
well our mom kind of goes around and um
helps clean up after people's mess are
they owners as well they're investors
they're investors so your parents bought
you this place yes
the moment we saw this place i knew i
had to have it so i found every single
way possible to convince my daddy no
matter what i had to do i just had
habits i personally think they could
have gotten it for cheaper and they
probably should have
uh what do you two do all day if mom and
dad are hands-on so what's your role i
do the bookkeeping i do the front desk
in the evening there was one day gordon
i had to man the dining room and the
front desk oh that was big sis i don't
know where you are i think you're in
minneapolis or something minneapolis
what are you doing back there when you
just bought a hotel i actually needed
some time to be alone and figure things
out so you take two weeks away then what
happened
she wasn't gone for two weeks she was
gone for three months
three months she's gone for three months
after being open for six weeks
i've heard your role
what do you do i'm seriously still
confused what my role is here i feel
like i don't understand i own the place
you don't know what your role is
i feel like a bunch of gas bubbles are
just flying all over molecules and atoms
just everywhere right now
did you stay here before you bought it i
stayed here um how many times uh once
once
you stay one [ __ ] night overnight
did you stay in here no not here in the
other room down the hall show me please
this is actually my favorite room
okay and this is it
so we stayed in this room you stayed in
this room this is even worse than my
room pee stains all over the disgusting
wallpaper holes in the wall here
why is this hotel in such a state
we have a lot of problems with the staff
it's so hard gordon to just repeat
myself what are the problems rudeness
unprofessionalism there is a chronic
disease here of complaining and
bitching so we've got a big problem with
the staff yes we do you're welcome for
the jobs you're welcome for the tips
you're welcome you're welcome
i'm in pipestone minnesota in a place
run by two spoiled sisters whose daddy
bought them a hotel
is that mold in there i wouldn't be
surprised they tell me the staff are the
biggest problem here it's so hard gordon
to just repeat myself but i'm not so
sure she wasn't gone for two weeks she
was gone for three months
[Music]
hopefully some lunch will brighten up my
disappointing day
hello how are you i'm good how are you
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
joslyn jocelyn nice to see you how long
have you been here my daddy i have been
here for two years two years in june
yeah probably two years i'm sorry here
it's just yeah and is your father gonna
buy you a hotel
never gonna happen even if i was like
please i want it just because i'm bored
not gonna happen right what would you
recommend do you wanna start with an
appetizer maybe yeah what's the soup of
the day broccoli cauliflower yeah i'll
try one of those okay uh entrees uh
let's go for the fish the walleye strip
okay um
man
it's a huge menu how many is in the
kitchen
uh two two chefs mm-hmm how do you get
this food fresh with only two chefs in
the kitchen and a menu with literally 35
40 dishes on there
you don't
does it need rice our venue here is huge
i wish we could use better ingredients
here in vanden arena they don't want to
spend
i would not spend my money here at the
restaurant no
i think the food sucks how are you mandy
hi
you're always running around yeah
amazing um
how long have you been general manager
um two years two years no disrespect you
don't look like a general manager right
i'm not that anymore um yeah [ __ ]
seriously seriously did you ever falling
out with them because no no
everybody's incompetent apparently
i'm sick of not really being the general
manager um i kind of feel like i'm being
pulled in all different directions i
don't really have a say in anything how
would you describe violence
vanda's borderline sociopath
um the other one i don't know i can't
describe her she's never here so wow i
appreciate your honesty thank you
wow mandy seems pissed i suppose if i
was working as hard as she is and the
owner thought the staff were the problem
i'd be pissed too thank you for the
broccoli cauliflower right get your new
drink thank you thank you
it smells bad
[Music]
taste it just a small bit
look
it is absolutely [ __ ] disgusting does
the chef not care um
no no
i don't think the cooks care anymore
but i feel like a lot of us have gotten
to that point
hmm okay walleye fish trip which isn't a
strip it's like a ball honestly
how old is that thing i've never had it
because i don't like it is it fresh or
frozen frozen but it looks like crap so
i would need
[Music]
everything who's the most assertive
about the sisters vanda cause rina's not
here
no
how committed are they you're running
the business
don't care
i think they look at it as like well i
own it so we can do whatever we want
sleep till three in the afternoon keep
the bar open until five in the morning i
mean how do you respect somebody who
does that oh no no no no no no
can you give me the owners and the chefs
yeah thank you doug you're welcome
the food here is horrific it's as if the
chef is cooking enough sleep gordon
wants to talk to you guys
now you don't need me here to tell you
the soup is that disgusting that even
before anybody tasting it it smells
burnt this is why we make our own food
i don't eat here anymore
unbelievable
right now i've got no idea
what's going on here have you given up
young lady do you hate food
what's going on
you still love my job
now i hate it
i can see
what's not working for you the owners
i'm not going to tolerate disrespect you
know we're not getting paid we're not
paying ourselves china's owners complain
about not being paid
you [ __ ] own the place
they don't have ownership of this
historic building
their daddy's not paying for everything
can i tell you something gordon
jenn has called herself the best cook in
town she's just told her picking on her
you have turned every [ __ ] member of
staff against you
i used to be really chirpy and happy and
i i can't even smile anymore
it's not about you yeah and i can't even
i can't even motivate myself to do my
projects anymore again just listen to
both of you
kill me kill me kill me you're only as
good as a team underneath you
whether you're here three months a
[ __ ] year or three hours a day it
doesn't matter yeah yeah
grow up
people have heard that i'm in pipestone
minnesota's calumet inn i wonder if you
have any openings yes and the hotel is
starting to fill up with guests
look at the hole in the door
i feel sorry for all of them
the wall people's hideous well the first
time my pasta was burnt i purposely got
the same thing to see if it was any
better and it's
it's not very sorry about the weight
where am i oh my god ah sorry
jesus you want you like some help nope i
got it thank you how many tablets you
got left to serve at least two three
four five yet it looks like five the
size of the menu are two cooks behind
the line oh yeah ridiculous i don't i
don't get it i mean i don't know how any
standard can be careful don't get it
with the place this busy it should be
all hands on deck but it's not uh
where's uh i think she's in the office
she's not there
okay now place is massive
i want to volunteer i want to help
people who want to join reno
are you up here
you okay yeah
oh
hi
can i come in
yeah
wow
is this your bedroom hi
this is my mom jorina's mom great to
meet you please miss your first name is
rita risa
you okay
i'm okay
but you look like you've been crying for
the last hour
i just didn't feel like being around
people right now i guess rita does
she always run away when things get hot
[Music]
what's become very obvious is the
lack of commitment
i feel like we should have purchased a
duplex or something like that
it's a bit late to think that now i just
can't seem to get up i know i'm doing
what i have to do are you capable of
holding the reins here
i want to start taking control but i
need room to grow i need base for me to
take charge
you need to get a grip
how about getting changed and coming
downstairs and just
facing the music
you can do that
thank you thank you
while rina's been upstairs crying about
nothing her guests downstairs have every
reason to be upset how was your chicken
it was really dry
it's kind of honestly one of the driest
chicken burgers i've ever had she can
bring the chick i will be happy
this place is a train wreck
all right and the coffee's complimentary
so oh there's oh wonderful and they will
bring you up a pot to your room thank
you very much you're welcome vandarina
might not treat her like a general
manager but mandy shaw works like one we
just have a little work down the end of
the dining room together two minutes i
want to tell gordon if things don't
change
nobody's going to be here the calumet
will close you strike me as the owner
because you are so busy every time
you're running
in the bowel in the lab in reception i
hate unhappy customers i hate i hate
that i can see how much it needs you
the two owners do they know that you can
run this place no we are all incompetent
to them wow what frustrates you most
about the two sisters um vanda is a
micromanager she's very um
cynical she doesn't even get up off her
ass and help if it's busy she doesn't
care
well this is what makes my house payment
i do and rina is a pansy i can't stand
that what is rina good at doing
cry
nah
are they qualified to run this business
no they should go out and work in the
real world first and the rest of the
staff your team that work under you
there is so much bitterness towards the
owners has this been building up people
are about to explode
the biggest problem at the hotel is the
ownership who are supposed to respect
ultimately doesn't respect us and i
think that makes people um
really not want to be a part of this
team the only
shining light in this building right now
is you
because if you weren't here they've been
[ __ ] thank you all right
thank you folks thank you
good night
i don't think vanda and rena have a clue
about how much they've really upset
their staff with their absences and
their high-handed behavior i need to get
the staff and the owners in one room and
try to get them to communicate okay when
was the last time all of you had a
meeting when we first purchased this
place so nine months ago
we're just so burnt out gordon so are we
first of all you guys i think you guys
need to understand that we live like
in four corner walls and we have no
escape we have we're living there nobody
made you stay and live here you know
what i think i think we know what the
problem is we step in their territory
and they cannot let go of their ego
here's the problem if you all [ __ ]
got to work i wouldn't be so [ __ ] mad
all the time i know one thing that i
come to work and i do my job where the
[ __ ] are you
mandy what kind of effect does that have
on the team when you can't get a word
from your owners it's really annoying
it's um it's passive aggressive behavior
um it makes people just very un you know
they don't want to talk to you then fine
you don't want to talk to us we don't
want to talk to you there's attitudes
but when we do there's attitude okay and
then that [ __ ] starts with you two then
see that's fine no emotion i'm just i
want people who are committed
committed [ __ ] you i've been here for
three and a half years i've done
everything from bar to [ __ ] pub to
housekeeping to front desk to serving we
want to know that you're gonna be here
that's the thing oh [ __ ] off i'm [ __ ]
done i'm [ __ ] done [ __ ] off committed
you stupid [ __ ] you just got here
i work 65 [ __ ] hours a week sometimes
70 and i have two [ __ ] kids i'm a
single [ __ ] mom it feels like i'm in
a woman's [ __ ] prison
i'm leaving i'm done
[Music]
i'm trying to save pipestone's
minnesota's calumet in but mandy the
general manager of three years the only
shining light in this building right now
is you
has just quit her job i'm [ __ ] done
[ __ ] off committed you stupid [ __ ] you
just got here
[Music]
i know a lot of people feel that if
mandy's gone i'm gone i'm gone i'm gone
i'm gone i mean this is getting real
ugly our general manager has just walked
out
you know the funny thing is no no no no
listen it's not funny that girl
dedicated her life to keeping
you
in a hotel have you ever employed one
single member of staff like she even
worked a day in her life
how could you say that you can't say
that you don't know me at all you don't
if you were here for two seconds you
know i've been running my answers
you guys don't see me do these things i
do them but you guys don't see it you
don't know the life behind all you have
no clue
for [ __ ] sake one of you step up
if you were my daughters
i'd kick you out
you can laugh all you [ __ ] once i'm
not your father
but what i do know is you don't [ __ ]
deserve this
thank you for the first meeting in nine
months
i thought gordon was gonna be nice to me
that was extraordinary the only person
actually cared about this place
mandy the general manager
has gone
those daughters are absolutely screwed
[Music]
i had a dreadful sleep i need to get
some exercise to burn off some of the
tension from all that screaming last
night
hey good morning hi how are you hi
brother how are you i'm good where's the
rough night that one
i'll go to the gym and do some workout
and swim
um what's uh what floors it on it's not
we don't have one in the building
there's one right over there
yeah
everywhere right over here like down
this street
it's like a rec center so i have to go
out the hotel
yeah
oh [ __ ] this no chance it's ridiculous
it's not there
a hotel this size with no gym on site
it's just another example of vandon
reena forgetting who's most important
around
here good morning good morning that's a
little catch up hopefully today i can
finally get through to them
good morning
these are
some of your guests
all i'd like to hear is just nothing but
the plain truth and give these owners an
insight to what you're paying for
so let's start with yours um i'll tell
you the room was very disappointing
we look for historic buildings when we
go places
and this was just a shame it was like it
was neglected it was run down to the
ground before we purchased this place
for 10 years you've got to stop blaming
people
madam please you give us an insight to
your experience well when we came in we
actually came in the back way this dark
hallway where freaking thunders yeah
dungeons yeah i entered that way i mean
it was like coming through an entrance
to a prison yeah
[Music]
madam please i have severe asthma and
allergies dusting the top of the
doorways and just caked in
white dust
it went beyond a comfort issue this went
to
a health hazard issue
i was literally worried about my
fiance's safety the last thing this
place needs is some kind of you know
wrongful death liability
would any of you come back to stay here
absolutely not
not one of you
thank you thank you guys
take care thank you
i'm so sorry the complaints from guests
are obvious things that a hotel owner
should be taken care of but these girls
haven't got a clue or a general manager
do you honestly think that you
are capable of running this hotel when i
want something bad enough and when i
have my mind up to it i always i always
accomplish at 32 years of age
tell me one thing that you've
accomplished in your life on your own
i worked when i was 14
at a fast food place
are you serious
you want me to get impressed with that
no no but i'm just saying
and
do you honestly think that you and your
big sister are capable of running this
hotel i want to say yes but i just
my head says no
i feel like a knife has just been run to
my heart
but i can run this place by myself
you have to be honest with yourself i
think we can make it with the positive
reinforcement that i use i would [ __ ]
myself asking you to run my dog up the
hill let alone a hotel
pipestone minnesota's calumet in is in a
dreadful state the food is awful it is
absolutely [ __ ] disgusting and the
rooms are just as bad
that's moldy oh man
and the owners are totally useless i
would [ __ ] myself asking you to run my
dog up the hill let alone a hotel
there's only one person that can help me
save this place
unless i can convince mandy to come back
and take on the role as a general
manager then quite frankly rina and
vander are screwed
and i will tell them to close the hotel
tonight
[Music]
hi donnie you got two minutes
[Music]
you had to be right to walk out how you
feeling bitter but i'm okay
nice to see you yeah watching the way
you work and the way you feel for the
place and how much energy you put in to
that hotel uh
you are a bloody good general manager
thank you you know your job thank you if
you were given the absolute control of
that place to run it
would you come back
that's tough i just i don't like them
i know and after everything that's been
said i don't
i mean i
i don't know
i just
i don't know
if i was mandy i don't know what i'd do
either
take care
and please think about it
i really don't know what's going to
happen at this hotel
arena and vanda are capable of change
do they have it in them to shoulder the
responsibility of this hotel
i need to have a proper chat with their
mum
yep
hello
[Music]
hi
it smells incredible up here come on in
what are you cooking i am cooking green
curry it smells incredible and who's
whose recipes are these oh
i just make up do you mind about a
little taste yeah sure
a little bit spicy maybe that's perfect
that is absolutely perfect my god
wow that is delicious that's the
tastiest food thank you i've eaten since
i've been here thank you
um amazing you're a very very good cook
how many times a week do you cook for
your daughters seven days a wing
those babies need to grow up yeah i know
that i suppose i spoiled him
when was last time you had a break
oh
not really
not at all
sometimes i get frustrated i tell them
you need to do the work by yourself
rina and vanda treat their mother as
their personal chef so she's stuck at
the hotel working seven days a week it's
time the girls grew up i wanted to talk
to all four of you to
shed some light
if you want to teach your daughters
responsibility like i have to as a
father with three daughters i buy them a
[ __ ] goldfish
not a hotel
jim do you want to be here
i wouldn't want to stay here on a
permanent basis
rita
no no
and do you want to be here
no
i don't
read him
i'm not happy here
i'm not i'll be honest
that's not what i'm asking we're doing
i'm asking you do you want to be here
no
i don't think you do either
you need to go back to minneapolis you
need to get into the city
that's what you need to do
thank you that's what i want
[Music]
i want us
[Music]
thank you
i'm sorry there's just something i've
been afraid to say
each one of you are actually trapped
inside this hotel what do we do
i would like you to decide as a family
would you want a proper general manager
to run the hotel for you or do you want
to sell it or shut it down
decision is
[Music]
yours the owners of pipestone
minnesota's historic calumet inn have
made a decision about whether to shut
the hotel down sell it or get a proper
general manager to run it for them i
have no idea what's gonna happen i'm
nervous
i'm very sorry for the way that you guys
have been treated and we have made a
decision here that we'll turn this place
around
and
that
means us
stepping out of the picture
tomorrow
there is going to be a new general
manager here
somebody actually in charge someone with
the authority from the owners to run
this place on their behalf
stay there let me get them for you
please
ladies and gentlemen
let me introduce you to the calumet's
new
general manager
good to see you stella's your team
after talking with gordon i realized
everybody that works there is like my
second family i care too much about the
calumet to allow the doors to be closed
i'm pleased you're back
you are an asset to this hotel
these two young girls
are leaving this hotel
this is exactly what i've wanted all
along i've always wanted a true general
manager to run the place and i would
come here on the weekends to help out
with the decorations they know that it's
not healthy
they know they can't continue oh i'm
beyond ready to give mandy you know full
reigns and full control as general
manager i have full faith in her
she's a very powerful very competent
very strong lady
tomorrow we are relaunching this hotel
and the new management and there are
going to be a lot of changes i want all
of you to get out of here and get some
rest because tomorrow is one hell of a
day yeah thank you
today everyone wins as the family is
free to leave pipestone the staff get a
proper leader and mandy gets the freedom
to be in charge
and overnight the interior of this
historic building has got what it has
long deserved too a wonderful
transformation
good morning hi
welcome to the new calumet
this is incredibly historic and a very
special hotel but now it's somewhere i
guess they're going to be incredibly
well looked after come with me
let's go
[Music]
disgusting wallpaper now we have a
stunning
bright colorful paint of kelly green new
mattress new box frame new linen new
cushions and a
bed to absolutely disappear in notice
how bright it is let's try and keep the
bulbs in the fixtures gym especially in
that rear entrance tunnel
gone is that dreadful rail in the corner
we replaced that with a wonderful tall
wardrobe how nice is that oh
beforehand the jacuzzi looks awkward now
we frame the bathtub with these
beautiful custom drapes so you can
highlight the fact that it's a stunning
jacuzzi but we've given it his own space
i'm blown away i mean you know guests
are actually gonna be happy to spend
their honeymoons here and we're gonna be
proud to actually show this room
this one is really special
i mean
yeah it's a a new addition please
welcome to my favorite room jump in
there
let's go
[Applause]
go on it's the bedroom you now have a
fabulous unique fitness center
where
guests like myself do not have to walk
100 meters this room is actually what
everybody needs in here when people are
stressed out when they want to kill each
other they can just go in there and just
relax
come and take a seat please
i've got something that is
really
going to put this hotel on the map
the food before like the heart you would
get from home cooking turns out the
answer was right under her noses rita
we've adapted your cooking style
rita's thai specials
rita when i tasted your food upstairs my
daddy
i was blown away
now the legacy is going to continue
a stunning
beef satay and then a delicious green
chicken curry and a phenomenal pad thai
thank you ladies
come on dig in
dig in
this is real hot
rita what do you think we're done
excellent yeah
i am very excited to see my thai food on
the menu it tastes very good yes
thank you so much
[Applause]
okay are we ready ready okay all good
ready to go yeah
with our rejuvenated energy the staff
are ready for the first night of the
calumets new life wow welcome to the
calumet in my name's mandy general
manager how are we doing tonight
good all right we have a new menu
five seconds good luck thank you you can
do this oh this is a whole new level of
thai food it's fresh really excited
about that something i've always wanted
to do and for the first time parents jim
and rita are enjoying their investment
instead of having to work at it much
better
1000 better keep up the good work yeah
yeah
when manly agreed to return it was on
the condition that reina and vanda would
be out of the picture unfortunately
these sisters can't stop interfering are
we good
excellent and were you still working on
that or would you like me to take okay
all right enjoy
how you doing tonight do you have a wine
list i can go grab you one
oh my gosh i had oh i remade our wine
list i had no idea the hotel can't
afford to lose mandy again with so much
at stake i've got to step in linda what
are you doing i am meeting and greeting
the guests
what are you doing hi i'm helping out
helping out let me just tell you
something you swallowing around looking
like you're here to take the cream
because you want to meet and greet the
guest you've actually done [ __ ] all
tonight
what do i have to do get back upstairs
and pack now
the calumets relaunch is going well and
the team are handling more guests than
the hotel has seen in years two rabbis
and a spirit i got it the guests are
loving the new rooms upstairs definitely
like the color the green really makes it
bright
it's a nice mix of old and new yeah okay
yup come back here and i'm really
pleased to see mandy stepping up and
taking control of a team as the general
manager i have to communicate with the
kitchen a little bit better there's just
one last detail to address rena and
banda need to hit the road
hello vanda are you finished packing yet
the taxi is on its way i'm going
okay ladies
taxi's here all right listen safe
travels good luck
okay thank you a little present for you
to teach you responsibility back in
minneapolis
please oh dear lord thank you now look
after them once you've got the hangout
looking after those then we can step up
to a cat okay the cat's fine then we go
to a dog look after those fish
good night
i'm gonna go off and pursue my dreams um
i'm gonna
travel
and continue onwards into my 30s a happy
person
not miserable
goldfish
don't drop it
will not drop the goldfish
i'm going back to minneapolis but i'm
really excited to feel free to let out
my creativity and show the world what
i'm capable of
look one is bigger when it's smaller the
bigger one could be rina the little one
give me panda
what a week when i first arrived there
were two small brats
that were playing at running a hotel
the change has been extraordinary the
key
to the turnaround
was in mandy coming back and standing
strong as a
proper general manager
this time it's a proper goodbye
and i
cannot wait
to come back and see you awesome
i believe in you you already have made a
big difference good luck with it
thank you
well done thank you so much good night
i feel like a whole new person i am
ready to just go full bore with this
thank you so much gordon
for giving me my job back and for
believing in me
i do hope those goldfish survive
it's 50 50.
you